India's prime minister Narendra Modi has
opened a new Parliament building in New
Delhi but opposition parties boycotted
the ceremony they say the inauguration
should have been led by the president
and not by a man they call a threat to
democracy Tony Chang reports
prime minister Narendra Modi is front
and center at this Inauguration in New
Delhi the ceremony marked the opening of
India's new Parliament building
friends this is not just a building it
is a reflection of the dreams and
aspirations of 1.4 billion Indians it is
a temple of our democracy which gives a
message of India's strong resolve to the
world
Murray took a central role in the
inauguration that many in his party the
BJP say is entirely appropriate for the
man who's led the country for nearly a
decade
in this case he is from the BJP but that
doesn't mean he is the prime minister
for BJP
is the prime minister of the whole
country but 19 opposition parties
boycotted the event they say that such a
prestigious role should have been led by
the president the head of state not a
man they view as a threat to democracy
you undermine the soul of the parliament
so badly
so how can you expect to leave a legacy
behind when you've done everything to
throttle democracy in the Parliament and
outside the parliament
the old Parliament building was built by
the British in 1927 two decades before
independence but it had outgrown its
role as the home but the largest
democracy in the world the new
Parliament complex is at the heart of a
2.4 billion dollar building project and
gives the legislature three times as
much space and 500 more seats
but Indian democracy might need more
than just physical space
if we want our parliamentary democracy
to work well not only will we need a new
building but we'll also need that Spirit
of cooperation consensus between the
ruling party and opposition
so that the spirit of deliberational
debate is retained
in March there were protests in the old
Parliament when opposition leader Rahul
Gandhi was expelled scenes like this
have prompted many to believe that
Indian democracy needs more than just a
new home Tony Chang Al Jazeera
Kavita krishnam is an activist and
author of the book Fearless Freedom she
joins us now via Skype from New Delhi
good to have you with us uh Kavita was
it right for the opposition to boycott
the opening of the new Parliament
and
because indeed
because it is a message to all Indians
of course but to the world
the Modi government is very keen on
making a break and establishing that
they are not in continuity with the kind
of you know Parliament Constitution that
India has had since its independence
because this is not about just a
building what they have done is that the
the Prime Minister leading the program
without any uh of the other
constitutional heads present and
the fact that there were only Hindu
um you know religious functionaries who
were participants in the event no
representatives of other religions and
India's diverse historical and cultural
symbols like the Indus Valley
Civilization the Harappan girl as well
as if you look at the Tamil you know
sector of the chora dynasty a monarchy
those things have all been used and
flattened out to give a message of Hindu
civilization and Narendra Modi as the
inheritor and representative somebody
who's going to restore That civilization
Hindu civilization so they um you know
for a while now this government has been
suggesting that democracy in India needs
to be in keeping with Hindu civilization
Indian civilization which is in their
reading in Hindu and therefore that
Universal uh you know ideas and values
of democracy are basically okay in
position and colonialism so where do you
to fear Indian democracy is going right
now
um I think that it is a very dangerous
scene indeed because it's not just
what's happening in Parliament if you
look just outside it on Parliament
street there is a protest going on by
India's uh you know wrestlers Olympic
wrestlers uh women who have won um you
know uh Awards One medals for India and
they are protesting against serial
sexual harassment you know tradition by
a member of an elected member A Member
of Parliament from the ruling party who
is a senior Sports official and uh he
has been accused by multiple women you
know Sports women and girls of sexual
harassment but you know the government
has not distanced itself from it
Narendra modi's party has been distance
and he is projecting him he's planning
to march with Hindu Saints at the temple
town of ayodhya which is a center you
know which BJP Associates
where does all of this leave Hindus
minorities
um
India is a diverse
person that can be supremacist ideology
and politics as a clip on the whole of
India not at all which is why uh you
know the Narendra modi's party has lost
elections in a state recently
um in spite of their uh
anti-islamophobic and Hindu supremacist
politics so I think that they are hoping
to turn the tide and somehow manage the
anger against this government by this
kind of you know Grandeur and display of
uh you know political power and
symbolism because there is an election
coming up parliamentary
Kavita good to talk to you many thanks
indeed for being with us Kavita Krishnan
there in New Delhi